at booktv.org or consult your program
guide
i'm john ziber the club's vice president
of media and editorial
the commonwealth club has of course
shifted from in-person programs to
online events during the pandemic this
is the latest more than 360 online
programs we have presented since march
and we are grateful to our viewers for
making these programs possible
we appreciate your considering
supporting the club and if you wish to
do so please text the word donate to
415-329-4231
or visit the club's website at
commonwealthclub.org
if you are watching our program live on
youtube today we invite you to submit
questions for our guests via the chat
box on your youtube screen and after the
conversation between our two guests i'll
return and get to as many of those
questions as possible
now today's program features annie
jacobson a journalist former
contributing editor to the editor to the
los angeles times magazine and author of
the new book first platoon
she will be in conversation with max
brooks a fellow at the modern war
institute at west point and author of
the books world war z and devolution
annie jacobson is well known for her
best sellers the pentagon's brain area
51 and operation paperclip in her latest
book first platoon she investigates the
age of biometrics and technology that
will allow the government to identify
anyone anywhere at any time
she delves into the pentagon's abilities
to utilize iris scans fingerprint scans
voice patterning detection by order gait
and more to track human patterns as well
as the ethical questions raised by what
ms ms jacobson calls a burgeoning
surveillance state now as i mentioned
she will be talking with max brooks
who's also a fellow at the atlantic
council's brent scowcroft center for
strategy and security now let's welcome
andy jacobson and max brooks
thank you everybody thanks for uh
zooming in uh
i confess that i just
read annie's book or i listened to it
and it's
it's an amazing read but i'm not gonna
i'm gonna tell you what it's about uh
annie i want you to i want you to jump
in and just give us
just a quick overview of what
awesomeness lies within these pages
well first of all thanks to the
commonwealth commonwealth club for
having us and max for having this
conversation
um i am a reader and fan of your work
and look forward to talking about some
really interesting things that are
affecting all of us today and the story
of first platoon
while it is set in afghanistan
and tells the story of
a group of very young
soldiers who are whose deployment to
afghanistan ends abruptly in
catastrophe and tragedy
it also tells the story about the
defense department's quest to build
the most powerful
biometric database in the world
in order to tag track and locate
people
and here's the rub before they commit a
crime
and that's why i think this story is
just as important today as it was in
2012 when the boys went through what
they went through
now uh for those of us
who are not
award-winning los angeles times authors
uh what the hell is biometrics just give
us a quick rundown what are we talking
about here
um and you know that was the very first
question i asked when i first learned
about this biometrics human measurements
so the most obvious ones are
fingerprints
iris scans
facial images
and dna
when i say obvious those are the favored
biometrics of both the fbi and the
defense department right now
but as we heard in the introduction
uh biometrics are expanding you know to
include the shape of the ear
the patterns on your veins
the heartbeat your individual unique
heartbeat these are all biometrics that
can be taken without your knowledge or
consent unwittingly the defense
department calls it offset technology
but the point of all of it
is to create these
massive catalogues of individual people
once upon a time
these catalogs that belong to the fbi
these big databases
had only criminals in them and that was
explained to me by the many special
agents with the fbi that i interviewed
for the book but now
these big data databases
have
information biometric information on all
of us
long before we ever commit a crime
and that really brings to bear this idea
that we're going to talk about which is
what is security
and what is straight up surveillance
right and so from the book uh you
describe the id that the whole point of
this was
that if
you
if you swept up into an afghan the u.s
military went to an afghan village
uh and then they could discern through
biometrics through fingerprint and
through dna and as you say in the book
dna is oh is it
nines
accurate
to tell say uh
an afghan farmer
from an insurgent
because if they if they captured
insurgents fingerprinted them
uh if they were released or if they
escaped we knew the difference
now
as scary as all this sounds
it also sounds like something as
scientific as dna
would be able to counteract things like
racial profiling
uh racism
uh politics because we know that that
certainly united states in the past
many people have been sent to prison
because of uh corruption bias whatnot
justice was not served and we also we
know that with the advent of dna uh many
people sitting on death row were
exonerated
so
is it is it inherently bad or is there a
good and bad
you know you raise this incredibly
important issue to all of this which is
what is the intention
and
because i tell the origin story here of
about
defense department biometrics
i think it allows readers to kind of
ask those very questions and then
explore them as we you know move forward
and in your own life and and in society
the
original idea
the fbi wanted to help the defense
department to be able to do exactly what
you're talking about to be able to
identify bomb makers saying you know
this is criminalistics this is this is
law and order base this is a great idea
but that very quickly went astray when
the defense department said to most of
the fbi special agents who were working
with them originally thanks so much for
the help but we're going to actually go
forward on our own and the reason that
created so many problems was because
the fbi's database
is are governed by
laws enacted by congress so there's
oversight there's legislation
um you can't just stop somebody at a
routine traffic stop and say open your
mouth i'd like to take your dna to see
if you're wanted for rape in another
state
okay
but the defense department has no such
oversight and no such guidelines and so
it gets very
complex chaotic and ultimately out of
control very fast because there's no one
watching the watchers
right and we should we should state um
we should remind everyone that the whole
reason after 9 11 the global war on
terror was given to the defense
department that was taken away from the
fbi was because
the defense department overseas could
move much quicker with much less
regulations because up until 9 11 uh
the
terrorists were watched encountered by
the fbi
uh but they lost that right because
there was too much oversight and there
were too many legal loopholes it was
believed that we could prosecute the war
on terror quicker
but
as you say now it's coming it's coming
back here
uh
so now what and you you just earlier
said the most two most important words
consent and
knowledge so
the danger is not that our government is
building a biometric database
it's that they could potentially build
one without us knowing and without our
permission so
what
safeguards are in place
and what safeguards do you think need to
be in place
well it's tricky i mean yeah back up for
a moment about the idea that wow isn't
it great if we just have a big biometric
database of all of us because you have
to stop and say
is that is that even a good idea i mean
you know people used to be able to live
off the grid they used to be able to say
thank you i don't want anything to do
with law enforcement with the fbi with i
just want to live my life and be a good
citizen i'll pay my taxes but leave me
alone and that's kind of a foundation of
you know western democracy that you have
that option and what we're seeing happen
now with these
biometric databases i mean you can see
it just right now with
all these
insurrectionists being identified from
social media through facial images which
is a biometric once upon a time it was a
mug shot then it moved to be you know
facial images and now we have facial
recognition software
and so
at the heart of the matter
before you even get to is this a good
idea or is this a bad idea because yes
we should as
you know the people be able to make
these decisions but ultimately they get
argued in the courts
and what we're seeing happening is that
the arguments in the courts about right
to privacy
about whether or not um people
are being you know whether if
if your
photo is taken while you're walking down
the street and that later comes into
play in a very public way
has your right to privacy been violated
those fourth amendment questions are
being debated in the courts
at a snail's pace
in the meantime
you have
these issues of you know
civilian justice civilian law and order
happening
at science fiction like speed just like
we have seen in the past week the big
fear among among
the lawyers that i speak to on this is
that
will some of these
cases against the insurrectionists could
they potentially be thrown out
because of these right to privacy issues
because i mean that's the fruit of the
poisonous tree argument that if what you
if what you garnered to build your case
on
was an illegal search and seizure
then perhaps it can't be used
right right and it seems like there are
there are clearly valid valuable
arguments to be made on
both sides
uh because like you said you can't you
can't live off the grid anymore uh
even if you're a law buying citizen but
by the same token
uh ted kaczynski lived off the grid
that's right
so
it seems it seems that you could make an
argument for both sides but it seems
like uh the arguments themselves
are not keeping pace
with the science and it reminds me of
the speech that eisenhower made about
nuclear weapons that when he was born
the weapons of his childhood were the
musket and the cannon
and now it is the hydrogen bomb
and he warned us he warned us that and i
can say this as a writer i can tell you
all the great science fiction of the
1950s and 60s was all about our power
racing ahead of our wisdom
but what do you
as someone who studied this
think could be done
for our
our society our rights our laws our
national discussion to catch up how do
we do that
okay so let me tell you the origin story
of the fingerprints for the for the
defense department and
i find this astonishing because it's
almost like a puzzle within a puzzle you
don't really know the answer so it goes
like this
um this is the moment where the defense
department started its biometrics
program shortly and i and i tell the
story from my interviews with the
special agent who is in charge of this
program named paul shannon
and he was
working in the rubble of the trade
center after the planes had taken them
down after 9 11 and it was his job as an
fbi agent to locate
finger printable body parts
that's what a grim job it was
and at the time he learned that the cia
the paramilitary organization and the
special operators were going into
afghanistan and we're going to be you
know going after terrorists within weeks
and paul shannon said to himself
we've got to get the fingerprints the
biometrics of the fighters leaving the
battlefield because these guys are going
to be really important and they're going
to scatter that's the basic premise of
asymmetric warfare you can just
disappear into the crowd
and
it's such a good idea that the director
of the fbi gives paul shannon and a
couple other special agents his
gulfstream
to go to
pakistan
and
fingerprint
the fighters that have been captured
leaving the battlefield all of whom
claimed oh i'm just one of you know i'm
just a cook because they were captured
near and around bin laden
shannon fingerprints all these guys
takes their dna
takes their
photographs hand carries it back to the
fbi
and the system the information goes into
the database
well
not a few months later he gets a phone
call that says you're not going to
believe this one of those 30 terrorists
in that
you know little tiny prison secret
prison in pakistan
he's been arrested in the united states
he's in the fbi's database which has to
mean he was here in the united states
and this is astonishing and as it turns
out
and i tell the longer version of the
book but this was
a man by the name of muhammad al-qaeda
who was in fact supposed to be the 20th
hijacker on 911. there were 19 hijackers
muhammad al-qatani was stopped at the
border
was you know
the the customs and border patrol agent
was suspicious of him rejected him and
his fingerprints were taken
imagine what the dod must have thought
in that moment this was a one in six
billion
person
match hit
and so
the long-winded that's a long-winded
answer to
my god imagine the good it could do if
we have these databases and know who
these individuals are and you can stop
them it could be the difference between
a terrorist attack
but that was a very long time ago and
technology like you said has moved
forward
at this incredible speed and we're now
in a position where these databases are
too big
they're controlled by a very small
number of people and understood by even
fewer
right well it sounds like this is the
age-old argument of
in in any democratic society of uh where
is the power
it's the same thing with with nuclear
weapons it's the reason that
um that every every time a nuclear
missile drill is conducted it has to
have two keys by two separate people
that have to agree little things like
that
it's the same reason that a policeman
must read you your miranda rights and
have you not been branded in you can
walk
uh so we have these safeguards
but
uh it sounds like
this is moving very fast
and i think i'd like to to
not segue but
point out that at least
if this is our government keeping a
database on us
there are safeguards maybe they don't
move so fast but i elect these
representatives who elect the judges
and if i don't like the way things are
going well maybe i should get more of my
friends to vote and maybe i should pay
more attention in civics class
however
these massive databases are also in the
private sector
and we learned this right after 9 11 we
learned that while we were getting so
angry at the bush administration for
collecting our data from our online
searches
google one of our biggest companies has
based its entire business model on
spying on us
and collecting big data so
what safeguards are there and and just
another fine point these many of these
corporations are global
china owns tick tock so every kid that
goes on tick tock china is building
a database on them so in the private
sector what are the safeguards
to protect our privacy
well there are almost none
and that is that's the bad news and the
bad news because
and i think even worse than the lack of
safeguards is the utter lack of
transparency right because the and or
you could you could say transparency or
you could say desire to know
i mean
you know
we could sit here and geek out about
biometrics and we are but at the end of
the day a lot of people say oh my god
i've got you know dinner to make and the
laundry to deal with and wait a minute
you want me to know about you know these
high falutin high technology big data
systems
i'm just going to trust that
this is being taken care of by someone
and i think the story of first platoon
makes
explicitly clear in just a simple tale
of a group of young soldiers in
afghanistan and the aftermath of what
happened how
all of those ideas that i'm being taken
care of that you just said as well are
actually not true they're not in place
they're not true and the system is
spiraling out of control far faster than
anyone is really catching up with
with the
a way in which to understand these
systems
in a simple manner not just a
esoteric
um
asymmetric warfare geek manner
well you you have the story one of one
of the
the through lines of the book is a war
crime that and we won't spoil it uh but
a war crime has been committed
and
uh the perpetrator was sent to federal
prison
however there was a pardon on the table
and the pardon is based
not on the biometric data but as i
understand it a lie
about the biometric data it's actually
the biometrics that would have done the
right thing the science itself would
have kept this murderer in prison
but it's the people who are able to lie
about it the same way they cover up any
evidence
uh it's guns or whatnot
so it's absolutely right it's it's a
twist on this idea that
science doesn't lie which it doesn't
but humans lie and so as you create a
more and more rarefied world where no
one understands biometrics they don't
understand how that how they can be
captured they don't understand where the
information goes once it is captured
then ultimately that information can be
used against you and
you
the the whole world
with the example of the rogue army
officer i tell in first platoon
he goes to leavenworth convicted of a
double murder war crimes as is
appropriate and if you read the book you
can it's all pulled from the trial
transcripts and you can make that
decision for yourself you can also
decide whether
whether whether his sentence was fair
but he is convicted he goes to prison
and then he is
released after president trump is
presented with
quote-unquote dna
that proved that the people that he
killed were not civilians but in fact
terrorist bomb makers i mean it's
it's sort of hijacking the public's
sentiments about
war and obligation and
and
the role of young soldiers in a foreign
country to fight america's war it's just
taking all of it turning it upside down
and manipulating
the reality of the situation simply
because people are too busy to
understand
what's going on but i
urge everyone to just pay the tiniest
bit of attention because
at the end of the day it's not as calm
it's a little bit like the emperor's new
clothes it's not as complex
as
it's made out to be and you know you
keep going back to the idea that we're
busy and it seems like this is this is
the issue and this is this is just basic
human psychology that we tend to
not want to deal with the problem until
we have no choice
and you could argue whether that is true
or not but you could argue that the
reason that kennedy and khrushchev did
not destroy the world
was because of hiroshima and nagasaki
hiroshima nagasaki not happened had it
just been a a bomb in an empty desert
without the horrific casualties that we
could have seen
kennedy and khrushchev would not have
been able to imagine that sort of
devastation all around the world so with
nuclear weapons you got a bang
and we put in the safeguards and as a
result we have had not had a nuclear
explosion in anger since 1945 but this
seems like if i understand this this
seems like a slow creep this seems like
something that it just happens it
happens it happens and one day you wake
up and you realize
oh wow my dna is everywhere
and and there's a story i tell
in the book that is very simple and
frightening
where involving dna because dna
as a biometric
is
both
powerful
um
in the criminal justice system to be
able to gather
you know evidence from a crime scene
that a perpetrator left behind no doubt
this is a fundamental of rule of law the
systems have moved from taking two years
to identify to 94 minutes you can now do
a rapid dna test thanks to dod money
but i tell the story in the book which
was originally reported by two new york
times reporters
where a 12 year old boy was called into
detectives in new york city based on
his
suspected involvement in a felony crime
he's offered a mcdonald's soda
which he accepts and when he's done with
it the detective wearing rubber gloves
takes it away takes the straw out
pulls cell samples from his lips
and that 12 year old boy
his genetic foot fingerprint goes in
to a database
he was later proven to have nothing to
do with the crime but it took his mother
an extraordinary amount of time in the
help of a big legal firm
to get her son's
genetic information out of
a database
that happens can happen to any of us and
as you say
it sounds a lot like once that happens
it's far too late
right and it seems it seems like we
would need uh once again it's not the
science it's the transparency behind it
because when you are brought in when you
are arrested
uh and you and you're brought to the
police station they fingerprint you you
don't get a say on that but you know
you're being fingerprinted your
so it sounds like there needs to at
least be if not consent
awareness
that you are being genetically
fingerprinted so at least you know that
that is happening so at least then your
lawyers have the ability to trace that
because like you said it was the dna
that got him off and you also mentioned
in the book dna got the golden state
killer and if you could just talk for a
minute about that that's the other side
of where dna can be a force for good
yes and i think i mean the concept here
that you're hitting upon is identity
dominance and that's why it's in the
title of the book first platoon a story
of modern war in the age of identity
dominance this idea that the defense
department or any law enforcement
organization for that matter wants to
dominate my identity
that's a bit frightening and what it
means is that they
can
and perhaps will have
all this disparate pieces of information
about me about you about anyone
at their fingertips pun intended to be
able to then
dominate the
situation
when
when the when the when the question
arises is this person guilty or not
and
that is something that
merits
a much larger that discussion than is
going on right now but you had a
question in there that i forgot
i i was talking about uh because we
talked about a dna and i was saying that
you also mentioned in the book about
when it is a force for good and that you
have several examples so first talk just
for a second about the golden state
killer
uh because when we say they have our dna
oh god what do they know what do they
know well by the same token there are
people who have something to hide
and have got away with it for what 50 40
years tell us about about that
that story is really interesting to me
for two reasons one i tell the origin
story of rapid dna in first platoon
through the eyes of its inventor a man
named dr richard selden a harvard
educated microbiologist and again it
brings up that theme of like
you know frankenstein versus dr
frankenstein like when scientists create
something that they believe is for good
and it gets out of their control
and you know dr selden
certainly presents a great case that
what he believes he has done with rapid
dna the ability to determine someone's
dna in 94 minutes what that means is the
perp that's in the police station is
still in the police station after 94
minutes and you're you're waiting for
the test results
whereas before it used to take up to 24
months the guy would be in the wind by
then
so
you have this idea that dna is moving
faster than we can keep up with and the
golden state killer
was found
through this
you know civilian company called jed
match just
two retired businessmen in florida who
were you know
sort of history
um
ancestry fans and they wanted to help
build a database whereby other people
could figure out who their ancestors
were again for the greater good this
idea that
you know
maybe um people who had been adopted
that were searching for their birth
parents and it became extraordinarily
popular overnight
but what was unknown to all the users
was at the same time
state and federal law enforcement
agencies were using this database taking
samples of old you know dna
maybe the cigarette butt of a perp of
something left behind at a at a murder
scene
and they were using this database to try
to do
what is called familial genotyping which
is to figure out who people are based on
who their family members are
and this is how the golden state killer
was found after decades on the loose
but what i also thought was particularly
interesting about that was even dr
richard selton who invented the rapid
dna test
he told me that he could not have
foreseen
what jed match was capable with familial
genotyping and that's where we're
talking about you know annie and max
can't think through
these ideas and what they might mean and
what might be next and what they might
foretell
and your analogy
with eisenhower and the bomb is so
important here
if the actual scientists can't imagine
my god what will become of this
what monsters can be unleashed and
that's not again meant to just terrify
people it's that old thing of to quote
eisenhower you know that it's the
knowledgeable
it's the informed public i'm
paraphrasing him
that is the key component to
making a democracy work
yeah and we should just take a step back
and and remember that that's why we have
these systems because
there's different types of intelligence
and you and i are both we know the
scientists we know scientists we've
worked with them
uh we also know that they get lost in
their own work and they get very excited
about they you know they are not
horizontal thinkers who see the big
picture they are vertical thinkers they
drill down
oppenheimer who invented the atom bomb
had to actually watch it go off before
he said my god what have we done
really you didn't know this when you
were you're working with your little
rubik's cube you had to blow it up
thanks hoppy
so
that's why we have judges and courts and
lawyers and journalists one of the most
important factors of a democracy
journalists who can inform schmucks like
me that go oh well
and i just i want you to talk for just
another minute because while we're
talking about our society let's jump
back to afghanistan
another example as i think i remember
from 24 hours ago
when
biometrics was a force for good that
helped encounter insurgency so talk a
little bit about the man in the purple
hat
well you know i
on the one hand you have
these young soldiers
capturing biometrics on the ground of
civilian insurgents alike the program in
afghanistan it was secretive not secret
was for the defense department to
capture 80
of the biometrics on 80 percent of of
all of afghanistan so that that's that
catalog that has to exist
then
on the other hand you have what is
called persistent ground surveillance
which is actually an overhead system
in an aerostat which is a big giant
balloon or other ways drones and things
whereby full motion video so that's
video with geo-location data embedded
inside of it
tracking
individual people who are anonymous
on the ground
but all of this data needs to be
processed by ai by you know intelligent
machines
that are run by a software system called
palantir because no human can keep track
of even one one zillionth of this let
alone all of it and so
these two systems are kind of working
hand in glove and
what was shocking to me interviewing the
the the persistent ground surveillance
operators are called pages operators
they were actually watching the movement
step by step of the soldiers in first
platoon this was completely unknown to
any of the soldiers
and yet the peaches operators are
watching the soldiers every time they
step off the outpost
technically
so that they can warn them of ieds
that are buried in the ground
because they have all of that mapped or
at least a lot of it
it didn't work out well that way at all
as you can read in the book and at the
same time the pgs operators are tracking
individuals who they think might be
insurgents and that comes to the story
of the man in the purple hat
and the peaches operator named kevin
gave me a series of these remarkable
interviews whereby he's watching this
man in the purple hat and he literally
has to watch everything he watches him
go to the bathroom there's no indoor
bathrooms in this area of afghanistan so
everyone goes to the bathroom outside
he's watching him do that he's watching
him pray he's watching him watch it wash
his clothes in the river he's watching
him go home
and he's always wearing a purple hat
what the pigeous operator is looking for
is what are called three interactions
with the earth
then that meets the qualifications to
kill the man
the government's
methodology in afghanistan is called
find fix finish the biometric systems
find and the pegis operators fix them
they figure out where they are and then
a drone is called in or another form of
aircraft to finish them meaning kill
them
and i tell the story of the man in the
purple hat because it indicates how much
can go wrong the peaches operator has
been watching this man they know he's a
terrorist they're going to kill him
and he comes into the outpost one day
and his colleague says we're about to
kill the man in the purple hat
and kevin the peaches operator says wait
um
he notices that the man in the purple
hat is on a very expensive tractor the
kind that really can only be used by an
actual farmer
and i won't give away the whole story
but suffice to say the man in the purple
hat became
came extraordinary
close
the the farmer
on the tractor
was mistaken for the man in the purple
hat and became extraordinarily came
extraordinary close to being executed
this is the kind of thing that can go
wrong right right because once you're
dead
you can't come back you can't say oh we
made a mistake
and you can't say check my fingerprints
it wasn't me it wasn't me no it's too
late when you use lethal force
uh there's no coming back from from
deadly force
but
now certainly after the capital
insurgency it looks like we are entering
a new phase of domestic terrorism
which we haven't seen since the 1970s
you know even my generation gen x
is too young to remember a time when
there were bombs going off all the time
when there were homegrown left lefty
insurgents groups everywhere and now the
right is seems to be doing it but now
that we enter this new phase
how do you see
biometrics being used in a way that
protects people's rights but also keeps
people safe because you know let's
remember when we talk about
uh surveillance law enforcement we're
not just talking about
beating up poor people or brown people
who are innocent we're also talking
about as you mentioned in the book the
guy who used to blow up abortion clinics
we are talking about stopping someone
from going into the next black church
with an ak-47 uh going into the next
synagogue we are stopping the next
person the next timothy mcveigh so how
do we do that do you see
this but at the same time uh not looking
at all of us going to the bathroom every
day
i mean these biometric systems
absolutely can be used part and parcel
to rule of law
as it is intended to work in a western
democracy i mean you have to have a
situation
it's part of the social contract to have
one group of people in charge
and
allowed to enforce rules and laws that's
the basic proponent and so in an
interesting way
if we want to be hopeful which i think
we should be
we can look at the situation that is
upon us now whereby we have
we we saw both ends of the spectrum
in terms of protests unrest and you know
civil unrest we've seen it since june
and it culminated
um
january
this past you know just a few a few
weeks ago
at the capitol
and
let's see
what law enforcement
does
with the biometric tracking systems but
i think it's going to be a great
opportunity for everyone to be involved
and to put their sort of best western
style rule of law hat on and say to
themselves
you know where does privacy factor into
this and what rights am i willing to
give up
for the greater good of society because
that's the fundam that's like a
foundation since the age of reason
we are all we agree as a society to give
up a little bit of our freedom for a
little bit of security and the line
always moves you know we had this
absolutely in the 60s we thought that
cops were going too far we even called
it gestapo tactics so we we put in all
these great rights and then in the 70s
maybe we went a little bit too far in
the other way and a lot of bad guys got
out
but now the needle shifts and the needle
is always shifting in our country and
that's a good healthy thing but if you
can you don't really talk about it as
much in the book but clearly you know
what you're talking about
just talk for a few minutes about a
country that doesn't
have that back and forth that we have
talk about the chinese
their big data and the trust index that
they are now building among their
citizens
well china is the
best example of all that can go wrong
right
and
china specifically has a program called
physicals for all
and this was a biometric tracking
program to catalog every single chinese
person of uyghur descent
and it is estimated that there that they
now china has a database of 2 million
weakers and this includes
their fingerprints facial images
iris scans and dna and the frightening
part about the dna it's believed that in
that way we talked about what jed match
can do
that the chinese government is doing to
actually
use the dna to determine who else might
be of weaker blood which sounds very
much to me like what went on in nazi
germany
and this is a frightening program it's
very dangerous and when it came to bear
by some great journalists just a few
years ago that have been covering this
story
human rights organizations around the
world went wild with you know this is so
terrible
not one single place out of all the
research i did did i ever see a human
rights person
make the connection that this program
is almost precisely out of the defense
department playbook in afghanistan
right so we should say that they they
are using without any safeguards they
are using biometric information
to racially profile
yes
an entire community and
i don't know whether you know this but
it would seem that the chinese communist
party
would then have a surveillance state
within a surveillance state
which would then curtail movements which
would then curtail gobs
which keeps an entire community
essentially in a giant re-education camp
so to my fellow liberals who i love let
us all remember that when we all tweet
about israel
we are doing this on a phone made in a
country that's putting two million
muslims in a re-education camp i saw
photographs of
uyghur cemeteries being dug up
and the idea
very frightening idea is that the
chinese government is going as far as
pulling up you know skeletal remains so
as to get dna
and build out this
database to racially profile anyone who
is even the slightest hint of weaker
descent and this is just you know
frightening on top of frightening
right
and this is the country that makes our
shoes and our iphones and everything
else and
we supp and we don't talk about
boycotting or divesting or anything like
that because god forbid we lose these
deeply they could be made in flint
michigan but
clutch the pearls we might have to pay a
little bit more oh no this time for some
questions from our online audience um
and here's a question really for i'd
like to be interested in either of you
or both of you excuse me responding to
and that is what impacts have biometrics
had on
your work you know any as a journalist
and a researcher uh you know max and
military strategy and of course
defeating the zombie menace um
has it had any impact noticeably on your
work or your access to sources and
things like that
annie you first
well you know i wrote a whole book about
it but um
you know um
i think that max should tell us about
how it affects science fiction because
sometimes
you can learn as much about a subject
reading science fiction as you can read
as you can reading science fact
well you know the role of the
storyteller uh is hopefully to teach us
something if we do our job right but we
all have an ego defense mechanism
sometimes if you if you give people a
little bit too much truth
um
people tend to tune out
but if you wrap it in a veneer
then you are able to get people just
familiar you introduce them to something
novel which annie does in her book she
talks about minority report
uh which science fiction movie but
minority report introduces us to the
notion of pre-crime you're gonna commit
a crime
and it really is a and now it's
something we really have to deal with
because as i was reading this part of
the book i thought oh my god i was
literally hearing on cnn the story that
the fbi had been tracking much more
dangerous
not protesters but insurgents who are uh
who are who are arming and preparing to
go to washington dc
and the fbi got in their way and said
listen you haven't committed a crime yet
but we know what you're planning and if
you go to dc you will be arrested and
they didn't go
and as a result a lot of shots were not
fired and a lot of blood was not spilled
so that was minority report in action
i mean i can tell you biometrics um
it happens to me in real life
uh as someone who after 9 11 has been
pulled out of god knows how many air
line
oh wow i can't say how many flights i've
been pulled off of in line
uh just because i mean look at me
in the days after 9 11
wow was i yanked off and that went away
for a while and then when i was coming
back from london with my family when i
went when i flew into the uk you know
you have to look through
and then they take the picture
and then first and then when i was
waiting to get on my flight someone from
british airways came in with a list and
basically said you you you you
and pulled us all out
and we all just sit in a little room and
my poor little boy was scared to death
did why are they taking daddy away
my wife's freaking out and i'm sitting
in the room with everyone we're all uh
different countries and we're all asking
each other
where did you go what what we all know
about algorithms what did you trip what
did you do this did i go here and i
looked around
and i realized
we're all [ __ ]
when no blondie's there
no blonde hair and blue eyes everybody
was either
my shade or darker
and
because i had no passenger bill of
biometric rights that was read to me
i don't know
and i think that's something that we
have to remember the algorithms the big
data
that that flags someone
it's not there yet
it's not perfect this is what annie's
trying to warn us about
is it's still a machine and you still
need human beings to look it over and
say wait a minute
your algorithm is wrong
and if we don't fix this you could
destroy lives i mean the worst thing
that happened to me was some time out of
my day
but what if it's something bigger
what if it's a drone strike what if the
fbi shows up at someone's door
uh
and
that person
god forbid gets angry this is america
we're all armed
flashes a gun and is then shot
so i i think i think what annie is
trying to tell us is that
biometrics as a tool of law enforcement
is not inherently bad or good but when
any new tool comes into the toolbox of
society
it must be examined and debated by all
okay
someone asks are there any ways to
fake out or get around biometrics they
say they're asking for a friend or just
headed in the direction of no way to
stay off the government's radar annie
there's almost no way to stay off the
government's radar however when i was
writing the book i went to several
different
biometric conferences one of which was
uh with an emphasis on dna
and here a little detail
that could be straight out of science
fiction but is science fact
um you know you could you could never
fake your dna right
well i listened to the story of a man
who had undergone a bone marrow
transplant for a very
severe form of cancer
and over time his dna
shifted to that
of the person who provided him with the
bone marrow transplant and my first
thought was my god this is what the arch
criminals you know the top level you
know russian spies are going to begin
doing to be able to
escape that biometric capture net what i
will say is the book i wrote before this
was called surprise kill vanish and it
was about cia paramilitary operators and
i traveled to a number of foreign
countries with a number of them while i
was
working on the book
including cuba and vietnam
and let's just say there was a lot of
tension going through those iris scans
that max is talking about because all of
them had big profiles
i can tell you that in the work that
i've done uh there's always a low-tech
solution solving a big solution this is
the history of warfare especially in in
the history of the united states at war
we always we love big tech
that's our bread and butter and
constantly in warfare we come up against
an enemy that has a stone age solution
now we thought when we went and annie
knows this when we went to afghanistan
we thought with drones especially drones
armed with thermal cameras with heat
signatures the day of the ambush was
gone there was just no way we could just
track them
we didn't realize someone had invented
the wool blanket
that the taliban uses a nice big thick
wool blanket that it drapes they drape
over themselves at night when they sleep
under it can't see them
so there are ways
uh
so someone asked you and that you
annie may have just really kind of said
this um but do you think we will
eventually have this full identification
and tracking of all citizens that we're
seeing china kind of rule out i mean is
this an inevitable thing and i want to
tag to that if it could another question
from the audience which is is this
likely to continue a pace
under biden as it was under trump as it
was under obama
i think that the i think the biometric
systems are nonpartisan i think the rule
of law issues
um you know have a little more to do on
par they they access on party lines
but i think that
we're only going to see more biometric
systems because
the big data systems that are
processing the data that's the that's
where so much of the money is and so
it's like the
defense department military industrial
complex you know or as one defense
department insider told me they call it
the self-licking ice cream cone
there are 85 million
ground-based surveillance cameras in the
united states we have the largest per
capita surveillance state and that's
larger than china per capita
i i can say that this this goes back to
a conversation i had with a friend of
mine in the intelligence community
once uh
the torture scandals came out in
guantanamo bay and abu ghraib because
remember the bush administration's
argument was uh
we need to torture these people we need
to waterboard them because god forbid
there's a ticking bomb
and if we don't the bomb is going to go
off and kill people so we are torturing
people to save lives and i asked my
friend i said has that ever happened
have lives ever been saved by torture he
said well i can't obviously tell you
that i said well then we don't have a
debate
that is only a debate if there are two
sides to an argument
and
when it comes to power any form of power
you in our society it needs to be open
and clear and then we the voter can
decide what is best for us but the bush
administration
uh set the precedent of the sheepdog
saying well we know better you don't
need to know we got this and we got this
doesn't work in a free and open society
then there's no debate
so
i'm i think that there needs to be full
transparency
and there needs to be a reckoning every
time something new comes in the toolbox
full transparency how does that work in
a time of when you've got very active
forces misinforming the public
active forces we we've all seen these
people saying ah the coveted vaccine
it's got biomarkers on it
yeah well that that's what annie was
saying that's this is in this is the
crux of the climax of annie's book is
this war crime is doubled down not by
bad science or by some evil hoodoo
voodoo technology just people lying
just people lying for politics
and i've done a lot of work on bio
warfare uh because we talk about
vaccines and really it it takes people
of courage like we've seen like in liz
cheney
to stand up to this fanatics and the
self servers on their side and we got
plenty of fanatics and self servers on
our side
so it's going to take
people in the middle to be able to
take on the wings
and say no no no
maybe that hurts me
but that's not true
that's john mccain saying to that woman
no ma'am he's not an arab
he's an american who loves his country
as much as i love my country and he lost
the election in that moment but he
gained back his soul and if we don't all
do that
then we will leave ourselves open to the
monsters in the box
it's absolutely a middle-of-the-road
issue as max is talking about i mean i
think that's the you know anyone who has
kids can begin to kind of see that
because
the extremes don't get you anywhere but
where
where the i think where the most
productive
discussions about how to move forward as
a great society that we are and all of
these liberties that we have and
balancing rule of law within that it's
being able to be a centrist about it and
not having such an extreme idea about
you know i'm right there wrong because
that is actually what biometrics are
trying to fundamentally do is to divide
people into groups us versus them
instead you know good guy versus bad guy
that's the danger in in all that's where
you start to have
totalitarianism come in
dividing people into groups
and i would say also that biometrics is
just another form of science and the
problem with science with data
is that sometimes it makes you not feel
good about the beliefs that you had
going into an argument
you know you believe something you feel
good you go in you look at the facts you
go oh i was a little wrong about
something and every every side is guilty
in this you know you talk about
anti-vaxxers
the anti-vaxxer movement did not start
in some rural town in arkansas it's
right down the street in my hometown in
santa monica a few blocks away we got
one guy dr death who said on bill maher
i believe vaccines cause autism but i
have no proof to back it up that's a
medical doctor
so if we
value our feel goodness more
and we value the objective facts
we are finished
we've talked for obvious reasons a lot
about uh
china and the united states and their
role in biometrics and such um what do
we know about other countries and is
this very widespread are the united
states and china the two most
um aggressive in pursuing this or are
there some others maybe uh that are dark
horses in this
dark horse is a good question because
those are the ones you always want to
look out for you know what is saudi
arabia doing who are they tracking with
their biometrics but um the indian
government
recently showed just how big and how
fast and how effective a biometric
program can be by capturing in less than
a decade
biometrics on one billion
indian citizens and that was for a
program for food that again the setup
was essentially well intended you know
the idea was people were handing in
their chits and sort of faking a chit
and getting someone else's food
and the the idea behind this was well if
we have everyone's iris scans we will be
able to authenticate who has been given
what
so good intentions but that's a billion
biometrics right there
i did not i did not know that
that's why you wrote the book
well leading up to 9011 there were a lot
of intelligence critics who said that
the united states had been over relying
on technological spying and under
investing in the on-the-ground human
intelligence double agents spies and the
rest that helped give information that
couldn't necessarily come from
intercepted phone calls or chat rooms um
is biometrics another lure into
misappropriating
you know
focus and money and and attention and
maybe under investing and other
big questions wow
we could spend a whole hour on that but
you know the question that i think maybe
the metaphor for that is science doesn't
lie humans do and so on that access of
human which the questioner is that is is
talking about human intelligence there
is always going to be
the balance that of the human
foiling
the science
and that's you know that's espionage
right
and you know and i would always say you
have to have a mix of both you know we
after all the black lives matter uh
marches
uh
there was this narrative that the the
rioters the the looters the bad guys
had infiltrated the pro the peaceful
protest
and had used that as cover in order to
do some really bad stuff now with
biometrics we would be able to prove
that
people say no no no we know these people
they have rap sheets a mile long
they've never been involved in any black
lives matter before they were there
to cause trouble but while you do that
you also need to have
the kind of police chief that we had in
l.a
who took a knee with the protesters and
by the way caught a lot of flack for
that
and said what i thought i grew up in la
i'm generation daryl bates
and i in my life i've never had a police
chief of the lapd say listen
my job is to keep the peace
and if that means taking a knee with
protesters i will do it i will do
whatever i have to do to keep the peace
so you need both you need science you
need head and you need heart
um
is there such a thing as there being too
much information being
accumulated for it to be useful or in
the days of big tech now is that
not a challenge in other words the these
agencies and and the forces we have the
issues that you've already talked about
about the human use of it but
is there even going to be a problem of
the
systemic understanding of this just from
so much that as tens of millions of
people's data biometric control gets it
gets accumulated or as i said is big
data
solve that
well that's the that's the end game that
i think is frightening which is where ai
becomes too important because
only
ai systems only system machine systems
that can learn can handle this data and
process it and there is simply too much
data coming in with all these
surveillance systems we now have
to be processed by anything other than
a.i and that is your military industrial
complex potentially gone awry in the
field of surveillance
yeah and i think we we have to remember
that
in an age of globalization
uh chinese companies are still very much
chinese russian companies very much
russian
american companies are global
and that's how they think that's their
business model we had tim cook remember
he said i'm not going to put a back door
on the iphone to track terrorists
because our first obligations to our
customers he met his global customers
he's not an american
but we have to remember that if
if we are not watching who our
corporations do business with because a
lot remember a lot of these big data
corps they farm out
to cheaper corporations which may be
contractors who may be working overseas
with other laws
you know we know this now
so it may be an american corporation but
if the server itself if that data is
being handled in another country where
the laws are very different and even
though we have the rights and
protections here at home our data is
sitting in kyrgyzstan
so i think we have to keep an eye on it
there's something that we have it's
called the committee uh it's a it's
called cyphus it's of an aerial disease
committee on foreign investment in the
united states
and it was specifically set up to make
sure that we did not farm out anything
from the private sector that could be
used against us
and we need to look at cyphus again with
the eye of big data
okay well we've now reached the point in
our program where we have time for just
one more question so we'll try to end
this on a
hopeful or at least a helpful uh
uh tone and that is we've talked about
you know certain types of regulation or
oversight or something that could be
done can maybe each of you give one or
two specifics on what you would like to
see as the government either comes to
grip or attempts to come to grip with
some sort of regulatory structure that
could
tackle what is clearly something that's
going to continue to happen
i think just the the slightest bit of
information and understanding and and
learning about the topic of biometrics
is brilliant and then from there you ask
yourself the question that max was
talking about earlier which has to do
with the fact that you know so
society does evolve and technology is
moving us forward and so we have to
think with a new set of eyes about how
to deal with this that means putting
away some of our old ideas
but really moving forward for me as
certainly as a parent that the idea that
rule of law
is a good thing
it's just that we have to
help the
law enforcers
work within
the
society that they now have and i think
that that comes from
you know opening up the lens of your own
perspective on what you think
might be right might be wrong who's the
good guy who's the bad guy and looking
at things sort of with a hopefulness
toward the new era that we are now in
i agree
i think one safeguard this is a
long-term safeguard that we could put in
place is get
civics
taught back in the classroom
because
all the kids i know they don't know how
their government works they literally
don't know about the three branches of
government they don't know about checks
and balances i think that that must be
taught but i would go farther i think it
should be taught by veterans i think the
money should come from the departments
of veterans affairs not from the
overstrap department of education
i think that our veterans many of whom
need a purpose when they come out of
uniform
should be retrained to become school
teachers and t
here is our constitution here are our
three branches here are checks and
balances here's our rights here's why we
have rights because a lot of them can
speak
not just from the head but from the
heart about
places in the world that they have been
where these rights do not exist
i think that we talk a lot about people
not trusting in their institutions
anymore they don't understand it anymore
you know
we need what is called a culture of
ownership again but not ownership in
terms of owning stuff
owning our institutions owning our
government that will start in the
classroom and it will it will be long
term
but
it took us 50 years to get from the
greatest generation to where we are now
and maybe if we turn it around in 50
years we'll have another greatest
generation
okay i'm going to add one last thought
on that off dovetail off of max's ideas
that i think the beginning the place to
begin with getting rid of your old ideas
and moving forward is precisely on that
for whatever reason
the sacrifice of veterans
has been sort of sidelined in the past
20 years in the war on terror and it's
almost as if
veterans issues has become an issue of
the republican party this is an
absurdity and i think both parties need
to realize the incredible sacrifices of
people like the young soldiers in first
platoon and the millions who have served
recently without nearly the kind of
acknowledgement that
needs to be
given to them yeah which and which also
does not mean worshiping them because i
think there's there's a
a lack there's an irresponsibility in
thank you for your service because we've
seen that since 9 11 where people go oh
thank you for your service you're so
amazing wow now go away in my dad's
generation nobody said thank you for
your service because everybody in some
capacity was serving even if it meant
rationing even if it meant blackout
curtains but everybody did
something
to contribute to the current events that
they were living so i do i i
i think that
the military has to get off its eye high
horse and we need to get off the couch
and we need to understand that what
affects one of us affects all of us
i think that's a great final note to end
on our thanks to journalist annie
jacobson author of first platoon which
you can purchase at your online or local
bookstore and thanks also to max brooks
a fellow at the modern war institute at
west point we thank you our audience
watching and listening today this
concludes this program the commonwealth
club of california thank you
you're watching book tv on c-span 2
every weekend with the latest
non-fiction books and authors